why hello there
people how are you doing on this fine
day it is
may 11 2021 according to the paperwork
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message and a quick note
to subscribe to our youtube channel bash
that button up there tap that
notification bell
and maybe you'll see our videos what day
did i say it was
it's the 18th did i say it was the 19th
i said it was the
there was a typo on the thing somebody's
getting fired today
no avocado for you with the chipotle uh
okay it is may 18th anyway there's a lot
to talk about yesterday was an
extremely exciting day for me
personally because i as promised on the
show yesterday when i was on the show
yesterday i realized that trader joe's
i was informed that trader joe's was
allowing
people to go into their stores unmasked
following cdc guidelines although that
is against
la guidelines which are still saying you
got to do it through june 15th but i had
heard some rumors
that people were doing this in los
angeles so i took my team my producer
and my director we went to trader joe's
and you're not gonna believe this people
we took video you're gonna see that in
just a minute then we've got this just
massive compilation of ridiculous joe
biden
things that are happening right now and
just none of it's good there's just
nothing good coming out of this
administration
or this man's mouth it's just disaster
after disaster after disaster
and speaking of disasters uh we'll also
be talking about the faucist
that's right the infallible fouchy uh he
has basically now just admitted that he
was lying to us
not lying to us about masks because in
essence he wanted us to keep wearing
masks
and he wasn't sure about the science
yada yada yada so we got a lot
to get to i'm ready to roll i got a
little bit of a stiff neck i slept a
little funny
the other day i'll be all right before i
get to it all
though i want to talk to you guys about
black rifle coffee
i'm drinking it right now guys you know
black rifle coffee is a
veteran-owned coffee company serving
premium coffee to people who love
america veteran ceo and founder evan
hafer spent over seven years on the
ground overseas
with u.s special forces and as a cia
contractor black rifle coffee is
continually committed to supporting
veteran law enforcement and first
responder causes
and our country and overseas courageous
frontline workers risk their lives every
day to protect
ours inspired by their hard work and
dedication to protecting their
communities black rifle coffee makes it
their mission to give back to those who
serve however they can
throughout may they are rallying behind
law enforcement officers firefighters
first responders active duty military
and other frontline workers by
spotlighting local heroes through
community
nominations donating coffee to keep
front lines caffeinated
and to give back to organizations that
support our nation's heroes they imp
import their high quality coffee beans
from all over the world and roast five
days a week
at their facilities in manchester
tennessee and salt lake city utah
the team at black rifle coffee is
continually researching and
experimenting with new roasting methods
and coffee origins
purchase at blackriflecoffee.com ruben
and use code ruben for 20 off your first
order including your first coffee club
order that's blackriflecoffee.comreuben
and now back to me and no joke guys i am
drinking it i'm drinking it every day
it's dark it's rich
it's delicious and it keeps me on point
when i'm talking to you
fine people okay so let's talk about
trader joe's so first off i want to
start here
with a quote from trader joe's last
friday this is this is last friday
they were letting people into their
stores it's quite incr
incredible we encourage customers to
follow the guidance of health officials
including as appropriate cdc guidelines
that advise customers who are fully
vaccinated
are not required to wear masks while
shopping so they're saying
okay the cdc has now said
if you're vaccinated you don't have to
wear a mask when you're in a store and
we're going to go ahead and i don't know
how many thousands of can we get a
number on how many trader joes there are
in the country that would be interesting
to know
but they said basically you don't have
to wear a mask if you come in
to trader joe's okay zippity-dippity now
the problem here
is that in los angeles we've got these
draconian buffoons in charge of us
or at least in charge of the masses and
they want us in lockdown until
june 15th which as you know i've said
many times it's just an arbitrary date
mostly having to do with gavin newsom's
recall well when my guys showed me that
yesterday i said okay we are gonna go
to trader joe's and get lunch right
after
we finish the show and that's exactly
what we did oh interesting there are 190
trader joes
in california so we went to our local
trader joe's and i took three videos so
what you're gonna see here is a
compilation
one is on the way one is at the store
and one is checking out go alright
people we are on
a scientific fact finding mission right
now
i am driving to trader joe's and as you
know
the cdc has said we do not have to wear
masks indoors
i do live in crazy california and
according to california
our ridiculous governor gavin newsom and
our more ridiculous mayor
eric garcetti they want stores to still
institute mass mandates which now
anti-science according to the cdc but we
believe
that you can walk into trader joe's
without a mask
and order you know food i suppose
or get other sundries and groceries we
will find out
this is all about science god bless
america here we go
i'm doing it i'm really doing it it's
happening
trader joe's it's incredible
freedom man we're back
all right people we did it we just went
to trader joe's me and my team we were
not wearing masks we were the only
people not wearing masks but nobody said
a word to us we had a couple people give
us some weird looks
but the cashier actually was happy that
real people were there he made a point
of saying it's nice to see people's
faces
um and i bought about 150 worth of stuff
uh i didn't need anything but i wanted
to give them my business so trader joe
whoever you are wherever you are love
you man i love you
i love traitor ming trader jose trader
giatto was that the italian guy i love
them all
trader joe's man you got a new customer
all right we did it people
we did it i went into a store without a
mask
i had no need to buy anything but yes i
bought about 150
worth of stuff i bought my guys whatever
they wanted michael only wanted potato
chips
i said you get whatever you want you
want a bottle of booze whatever you want
he only wanted potato chips
uh but we made it and really the key
part of this whole
thing is that the cashier so not only
did no one say anything to us we got a
couple of weird looks
but you know part of sort of what's
going on here is that you know we seem
to be in this world where we think that
everyone's a karen like if you
if you go ahead and live your life that
you're going to get screamed at by all
the karen's
but in many cases i actually think it's
the opposite because
the people who are the most brainwashed
they're also the most cowardly so if you
just go ahead and live their
your life they're not going to attack
you in most cases yes there'll be some
cairns here or there
but generally they're not going to
attack you and i actually felt that that
some people were pretty impressed
that there were three relatively young
people shopping at trader joe's without
wearing masks on their face
i mean is that a sentence that anyone
could have imagined anyone saying two
years ago
right like are we in fallout right now
what the hell's going on here uh but
really the nice part of the whole thing
was the part that i said about the
cashier
because it was so obvious that he was
happy he
said it's so nice to see faces and
really think about a statement like that
like we
really have done something so dangerous
and destructive to society
and i am just thrilled that we could
give trader joe's a little money and do
that but then
because los angeles is a horrific evil
place
the public health director barbara
ferrer
yesterday announced this i mean this is
just incredible
she said our teams are out notifying all
of the chains that have made
announcements nationally that they would
be relaxing their masking requirements
masking requirements are in place here
and all across california
so this is going to be pretty easy for
businesses and customers
residents and visitors to understand
because there's one
standard for the whole state and it
requires that we continue to wear masks
until june 15th so barbara ferrer
she is just she's just another one of
these evil bureaucratic morons
nobody got killed at trader joe's
yesterday but basically they're cracking
down
on private companies right to do what
they want a private company's right to
follow the cdc
these people are all awful you know i
tweeted it this morning i think
basically what we're gonna have to do
when when the dust settles on this thing
if the dust ever settles
we're not to jail a lot of democratic
politicians because
it is going to become increasingly
obvious because you because lies can't
last forever
and it's going to become increasingly
obvious that they didn't follow any
science
they made up everything that they're
doing they decided to use power that
they actually don't really have
as government officials i don't know
what right the la county public health
director
has to say that what she says supersedes
what the cdc says
not that what the cdc says is a law
either right
so it's all messed up but we've got to
get rid of these people and it's and
it's a damn shame so i wonder what would
happen now
and i and i would actually i'm not even
going to test it you know why i'm not
going to test it
because i would feel bad actually for
the poor security guard or the
or the poor cashier or manager of trader
joe's who would have to deal
with the nonsense if me and my guys
walked in there without masks you know
what i mean like if he was just at that
point
just doing his job and was like guys you
really can't come in here without a mask
and then some idiot
puts it on video and everything else so
we'll we'll let it be for now but i just
want to say that yesterday was a
spectacular day i will be eating salmon
from
trader joe's tonight i got a couple
bottles of wine
a bunch of other stuff and man we just
got to keep fighting just keep fighting
guys you know these people are just
all horrible and none of them are better
than you
none of them are following the science
they're they're just
terrible human beings who are grasping
their last
grasp for power is here and they know
that the jig
is up all right let's move on uh from
la specifically i think you get it it's
a [ __ ] [ __ ] hole
let's move on to let's move on to joe
biden
he is the president of the united states
or at least he's the guy that stands
there and repeats the stuff they tell
him
to say this is video from the
independent
on what he thinks about not vaccinated
people
if they do not states with low
vaccination rates may see
those rates go up may see this progress
reversed
ultimately those who are not vaccinated
will end up paying the price the
vaccinator will continue to be protected
against severe illnesses
but others may not be if you're not
vaccinated
wow that was a short clip but a lot of
nonsense in there first off he says that
rates may go up
in states that are not forcing people to
vaccinate well that is true
anything is possible in the future rates
could go up they could go down
we actually know that the second texas
got rid of the regulations
that basically the numbers completely
bottomed out and if i'm not mistaken
there were zero
covid deaths in texas yesterday and in
most
days since they got rid of the
regulations which it's been about what
five six weeks now
they've had zero to 20 deaths so pretty
much nothing and especially when you
factor in the comorbidities and all that
he also says that the vaccine will cover
severe
illnesses now that was probably just a
a reading error off the prompter by him
but what does he mean is he telling us
that the covid maxine
covers other illnesses too like i'll
just chalk that one up to
to joe b and joe but just generally like
the fear
just the endless fear with this guy it's
just
absolutely awful and again completely
anti-science because we know
that the states that are opening up have
lower rates by the way
let's just be very clear about this i'll
get a little ahead of the curve on this
if there was to be a bump
in texas or florida the the government
meaning the biden administration
and the media would love it they would
love there is nothing more than they
would love
to see dead people in texas and florida
i genuinely mean that they
because this isn't about covet and this
isn't about saving people's lives this
is about keeping people under the boot
of government
so they would love if suddenly there was
an outbreak
in texas they would absolutely love it
really really really love if there was
an outbreak
in florida because then they could
really go after
desantis so it is just a depressing
reality at that level
but if you think if you think what biden
said there was insane
just listen to what he said about martin
luther king and george floyd this is
from reuters
this is yesterday but even dr king's
assassination did not have the worldwide
impact
that george floyd's death did
dr king's assassination did not have the
worldwide impact that george flory
george floyd's death did you know the
sad part of what he said there is this
might be
sort of true biden might have sort of
got one there
meaning that because of social media
because of
hysteria in politics because of sort of
the ending of liberalism and the
complete destruction
of our trusted class of people and the
complete meltdown of mainstream media it
is possible
that george floyd's death may may
have a bigger impact worldwide
than mlk's assassination the reason
being because now it's morphed into
something else there was this thing
sitting behind it this really this crazy
marxist blm antifa movement
ready to use it as the fuel to burn down
the system where when mlk died we
actually kind of came together
a bit after and of course mlk was also
trying to defend
the ideals of america which are equality
not equity so biden sort of got it right
there but
what he's also kind of saying is that
this new thing this new movement is
kind of better than the old movement
right like that
that's kind of what sits behind it is
that oh the george floyd thing and all
the things that have happened now
these are the good things that needed to
happen and and you know 40 50 years ago
when mlk died it didn't cause all
those things to happen now the question
is are those things good or not and i
think you know my answer on this these
things are not good equity
is not good systemic racism that they're
doing right now and
and quotas and affirmative action all
these things these are not good these
are these are
racist things uh but i'll give biden a
little bit of credit because he
kind of got it right connor can we pull
that clip up again because if you didn't
see it
if you didn't see it uh he actually
oh is that right oh you know i'm being
told that this clip
is actually from last june not from
yesterday
well everything i said stands uh but
that's interesting to find out but
everything i said
absolutely stands it's in a weird way
it's even more bananas actually
now that this thing has has jumped up a
level and he wasn't even president back
then
but put the clip up for one more second
because look where the mask is on his
face
but even dr king's assassination did not
have the worldwide impact
that george floyd's death did
is there any chance he knew that the
mask was hanging on his ear at that
point and why then could he take a mask
off indoors if that was in june which i
didn't even know when i was
playing the clip right like it's all so
stupid but if you think all of that is
stupid if that's not enough for you we
got more this is from newsweek on some
of the things that joe biden's been
doing this week
president joe biden has quietly killed
four executive orders that his
predecessor donald trump
signed before leaving office including
one that sought to create a garden
of statues honoring american heroes and
one that trump signed
after twitter labeled his tweets
misleading so the four things that
joe biden has gotten rid of that trump
put in there via executive action and
this is not a commentary on executive
action
if anything this proves why executive
actions aren't great because one guy
puts him in the other guy gets rid of
him
one preventing online censorship you'd
think that biden would be against that
right i mean wouldn't that be an
american ideal we'd be protecting
protecting american monuments memorials
and statues and combating
recent criminal violence that was
because of all the statues being taken
down
and burned down and all that kind of
stuff and graffiti and all that but
biden's i guess
for all that kind of thing uh three
building and rebuilding monuments to
american heroes that's a sort of
offshoot of the previous one
and four rebranding united states
foreign assistance to advance american
influence so without getting into the
specifics of
all of these things you can see there's
a general theme here which is that trump
tried to do some things that were sort
of pro-america
that were against the ever-encroaching
marxist
ideology right like that's what trump
was trying to do and biden's getting rid
of all that i will add to this
that when i was at the white house
holiday party in december
before that i was actually asked to sit
in in a meeting i was not speaking at
the meeting i was just sitting in at the
meeting
where they were talking about the 1776
project and this is
where the administration was trying to
get some pride in america
back into the schools that is good they
were trying to get
actual history taught not to say
that america is and has always been
perfect
but to give an honest assessment of our
history
more based in reality and truth and a
pride
of this incredible wonderful country
rather
than the 1619 project and all of the
awful crap that is being pushed and the
critical race theory and all the evil
stuff
that is being pushed in our public
education system by
uh jo trump put that in and then in
essence biden just killed it he it was
one of the first things he did he just
absolutely killed it
and when i was in the meeting they were
already talking about how
assuming trump is not president because
this was after the election
assuming trump is not president by
january they were already trying to
figure out well how can we still do this
at a private level how can we make sure
america's youth
grow up being proud of america and
american values and all of the wonderful
things that we know are so great about
this country and i will continue
to fight for those things but biden felt
that that should get out and that we
really should be focusing on critical
race theory
and uh just the equity and diversity and
all of the nonsense
um one more for you this is from c-span
uh jen
pasaki you know i love pasaki well she
was asked a question by an npr
journalist about the cdc flip on mass
mandates that we were just talking about
i want to also switch to koben the
largest national
nurses union is saying that the cdc
guidelines on mass is putting frontline
workers
and especially people of color at risk
and that they're they're calling for the
cdc to reverse that what's the white
house's stance
on that union in particular saying that
they're they're members and people of
color at risk
well i would say we don't have any
particular response to directly to
the union i will say that again uh the
objective of the cdc and of dr valencia
was to
uh to deliver on the commitment she made
to the american people which is to
provide
guidance based on health and and
scientific evidence
on what people can do that is safe
yeah you know they just can't
say anything honest they just
can't also they try to racialize the way
the npr journalist there is trying to
racialize the question people of color
are going to be affected by this
this is sort of what a dying system can
choke out this
this ain't good pasaki is not good and
let's
now throw to a clip of fouchy
basically admitting that the indoor
mask situation over the last couple of
weeks was not based on science but was
purely political
how has it changed what you do when you
wear a mask
excuse me how has it changed what you do
how does it change your mask wearing
practices
well you know george i'm obviously
careful because
i mean i'm a physician and a health care
provider i am now much more
comfortable in in people seeing me
indoors
without a mask i mean before the cdc
made the
recommendation change i didn't want to
look like i was giving mixed signals
but being a fully vaccinated person the
chances of my
getting infected in an indoor setting is
extremely low
and that's the reason why in indoor
settings now i feel comfortable about
not
wearing a mask because i'm fully man i'm
fully vaccinated
fauci is an extraordinary fraud did you
really hear what he said right there
he's now
more comfortable being seen indoors
without a mask he's not saying that you
couldn't be indoors without a mask he's
not saying that the science changed
he said that he was trying to in essence
do propaganda to keep everyone in masks
forever by the way rand paul confronted
him on this
in congress not too long ago and he lied
about it then
too this is seriously dangerous stuff
that man is supposed to be
someone we're supposed to trust about
the science and he's telling you
that it was optics because nothing
changed in the science in the last two
weeks
the cdc guidelines changed but nothing
changed in the science by the way this
is something that joe biden remember joe
biden a couple weeks ago said the same
exact thing they said well wait a minute
joe you're vaccinated everyone around
you is vaccinated you're outdoors right
now why are you wearing a mask
and he basically bumbled out he was like
oh well it's optics it's optics
so what do you mean it's optics why
would you guys want optics
that go against the science and of
course here's video this is of today
of joe biden fumbling with his mask
outside even though everyone around him
is vaccinated and wearing masks and
they're outdoors
i'd love to know what uh doctor you know
she's a doctor
jill biden was doing there did you see
when she kind of raised her hands like
this
like she seems like she's kind of
frustrated at you like ah you old idiot
what are you doing put your mask on
let's throw to that again
so just to be completely clear for
everyone a little slower here
what happened there is three people who
are all vaccinated who are all outdoors
at least two of them are married to each
other i'm not sure who the other person
is
are completely going against cdc
guidelines for optics to keep the rest
of
you in masks and if you think that this
is just an aberration if you think that
fouchy lying
and you think that biden with his
theatrics if you think these are just
aberrations well i've got a tweet just
from the last hour from congressman
thomas massey of kentucky
here we go he says thought america might
like to know this
few congressmen or staff or guards are
wearing masks in the hallways
or offices only on the floor for tv
it's all theatrics folks
like how much more do you need aoc she's
not wearing a mask privately and if you
think you
she is i mean man like none of these
people are it's theatrics to see how
long they can control you and as i've
been saying
we kind of failed as as americans and i
would include myself in that too i'm no
better than anyone else i i talk about
this stuff and i try
to live my life you know congruently
with the things that i
talk about here but we all failed in the
last year and a half i think that
is kind of obvious like they got us to
do all this ridiculous stuff
and in the course of it we peered behind
the curtain
we saw that oz is not the all-powerful
magic
oz who controls the world but it's just
a bunch of bureaucrat
losers who just can use levers of power
and fear
to control us and we kind of failed
because
even now we still are giving them some
sort of power over us and i don't know
how we
get through that and i think what
ultimately will happen
is what i talked about uh with michael
malus just earlier this week and part
two by the way
just went up this morning which is that
americans will continue
to figure out where they want to live
and the red and blue thing if you
thought that the red and blue thing
was bad or unhealthy or whatever it is
it's going to get
continuously more polarized and in an
odd way and here's the silver lining
part and you know yesterday i talked to
you guys about the clown pill which is
when you get to the point where you're
just making fun of all the stuff but i
would also add to that
when you can smile about it and see a
silver lining in it and all of that
and what that is is that maybe this is
exactly what was supposed to be
maybe maybe the union can really only
hold in that we are different states
that hopefully aren't at war with each
other
but basically if you live in florida
it's going to be seriously freaking
different than if you live in california
and maybe that's just
the way that it's supposed to be if you
want more on that i had a really really
fascinating interview with michael malus
i know clip one did incredibly well we
just put up clip two and the guy is just
one of the great political
thinkers that we've got and i would i
would say even beyond politics he's just
one of the great sort of renaissance
men you can't even describe him i call
him the willy wonka politics
but you can't really describe him so
part two is up right now
on the youtube and of course the full
episode is up five days early
ad free as always at
reubenreport.locals.com
uh prageru by the way just joined locals
yesterday and it was pretty spectacular
because they were trending on twitter
and people were calling for their
cancellation and everything else
and we helped make them cancel proof we
don't have all the answers yet there's
there's big tech stuff here
you know technological answers
philosophical answers legal answers but
we're working on all that
stuff we're going to be testing uh i
don't know if you want me to tell this
but here we go
we're going to be testing live video
streaming uh in the reuben report
community next week and then eventually
we'll have live tipping in there and
we're just rolling out tons of new
features
got a great amount of stuff happening so
i'm i'm psyched i'm feeling good
have a great day everybody if you want
to wear a mask
wear a mask if you don't want to wear a
mask don't wear a mask
and remember we're only a free country
if we can keep it
and i love this place and i'm going to
continue to fight
to keep it and i hope you will as well
have a great day and i'll see you guys
tomorrow